jeden tag neue verrückte tram news und
jetzt begrüße er eine in den usa
geborene schweizerin was für eine
mischung hazel programm eine damen und
herren
wie stehst du als halber amerikanerin zu
der ganzen trump history bist du auch so
wütend und aufgebracht wegen der mann ja
ich finde man muss ja auch ein bisschen
nachsicht haben mit trump also nicht mit
dem politiker aber mit der person donald
trump ich war noch nie mit ihm in einem
raum aber wenn ich mir so eine rede von
ihm an höhere oder nur schon foto von
ihm anschauen oder ein tweet lese dann
merke ich wie ich von minute zu minute
dümmer und aggressiver werde und trump
selber ist ja seit 71 jahren 24 stunden
am tag mit sich selber in einem raum
also seit seiner geburt 1946 war donald
trump noch nie irgendwo wo donald trump
nicht auch gleichzeitig war fällt ihr
das mal vor ist ja klar dass der total
emblem geworden ist wenn ich mir den
ganzen tag lang diesen bullshit anhören
müsste der aus diesen niedrigen schiphol
von einem mund raus tröpfelt dann würde
ich natürlich auch irgendwann anfangen
das zu glauben und jetzt ist er raus
gekommen dass der arme nicht mal dement
ist das heißt er weiß am nächsten tag
dann immer noch wie grauen auf der iss
[Applaus]
jetzt gibt es ja in den usa einen ganz
interessanten trend nämlich dass immer
mehr junge leute in die politik gehen
sich um ämter bewerben und zwar aus wut
über die politik der alten wie siehst du
das als junger mensch ja gut das ist
auch ein riesiges problem dass so viele
alte leute über eine zukunft
entscheidung von der sie dann gar kein
teil mehr sein werden also wenn ihr uns
die welt als sehr großen aufzug
vorstelle ja so langsam durchs universum
schippert dann machen es die alten so
dass sie kurz bevor die aus dem lift
aussteigen noch schnell rein furzen und
wir jungen leute müssen dann mit diesem
stift weiterfahren und vor allem allen
die neu dazu kommen erklären dass das
nicht wir waren ist total mühsam aber
ich verstehe auch dass die alten leute
kriegen natürlich torschlusspanik weil
sie merken dass sie vielleicht doch
angst vor dem tod haben und dann wollen
sie halt irgendwas verrücktes noch
machen solange sie können weil kann ja
sein dass tut sein mega scheiße ist das
kann man nicht beweisen
dann ist man tot und denkt sich bei ich
fand leben schon nicht so geil aber
jetzt tobt kann man dort und vielleicht
bin ich ja dann irgendwann tot und dann
wache ich auf in einer riesigen
mehrzweckhalle und dann kommt so ein
dicker dicker mann auf mich zu in einer
viel zu engen fahrrad hose und ich denke
mal links träger interessant und dann
schaut er mir tief in die augen und sagt
hallo ich bin der ralf und das ist der
himmel
das kann sein dass das passiert man kann
es nicht nachweisen
und ich würde mich dann ja selber drüber
aufregen dass ich nicht konfirmiert
wurde weil ich mit vierzehn so damit
beschäftigt war cool zu sein und mich
nicht von irgendeinem halb pädophile
mann belehren und belästigen lassen
wollte er doch viel wäre ja nicht
konfirmiert sondern gefilmt aber auf
jeden fall
auf jeden fall ist so eine schlechte
wahl wie trump natürlich super für leute
die das ganze zwar nicht mehr ausbaden
müssen die aber trotzdem mit der
gewissheit sterben wollen das früher
tatsächlich alles besser war
dabei soll er jetzt nicht aus der
sendung raus gehen was würde denn helfen
trotz trump wieder etwas optimistischer
in die zukunft zu kommen ja ganz klar
drogen also dass
[Applaus]
erleichterung des publikums wenn man
endlich mal über drogen spricht aber
drogen twitter in den usa als auch
gemacht also noch nie wurden in einem
land so viele opioide missbraucht wie
2017 in amerika ist natürlich traurig
aber wenn man die qual der eigenen
existenz ausblenden will dann ist so ein
rausch natürlich eine sichere bank das
was die csu schon lange
ich nehme im moment gar keine drogen
zeige ich viel zu wenig für meinen
eigenen geschmack aber ich habe die
perfekte droge für mich auch einfach
noch nicht gefunden also ich will gerne
was das nicht so richtig relaxt wo ich
aber trotzdem gleichzeitig noch ein
bisschen arbeiten und funktionieren kann
also vielleicht sowas wie heroin schorle
wobei ich glaube es ist mega tödlich
wenn man sich dann so mehrmals am tag
kohlensäure in die venen spritzt und so
eine zweite amtszeit von trump will ich
schon noch gerne erleben ja auch hayes
der drucker meine damen und herren
[Applaus]